stranger things is
a pretty nasty show containing a ton of
gooey prosthetics and farty boys that
are smelly enough to evacuate a bus
several times over ready to find out who
the worst offender was number one we're
kicking it off with something sticky
actually pretty much everything in this
list consists of sticky things that
would have been a good alternate title
for the show putting on gross nasty
prosthetics and seeing yourself in the
mirror is one thing taking off gross
nasty prosthetics is a much stranger
thing but we've got to admit playing
around with prosthetic goo does look
pretty satisfying
slimy yet satisfying as simba would say
number two beards are gross in general
go clean shaven boys kidding a nice
beard can do wonders for the jawline in
the case of david harbour he had way
more than just a beard and it did the
opposite for his jaw he had to get
suited up in a prosthetic that reflected
the weight he was in season 3 for the
flashback scene so that means that that
neck isn't real that's a fake
beard with fake
beard hair oh boy that's a little
strange downright uncomfy harbor can't
stand prosthetics but the process for
this one was pretty painless thanks to
an awesome team
number three oh dear what direction
could we possibly go with this turns out
that lube has more than one purpose it's
great for maneuvering in prosthetics
jamie campbell bauer had the honor of
slicking up for vechna the product isn't
just great for prosthetics though did
you know your friendly neighborhood
spider-man had to use lube to get into
his spidey suit and no way home or at
least tom holland did at any rate oh to
spend an entire day slimy just sounds
like a nightmare number four and now for
the most disgusting thing on this whole
list
kissing matt duffer acknowledged that it
was easy to forget how young milly was
sometimes because she's so incredibly
gifted for her age
well her age would shine through
sometimes of course like when it came to
kissing finn wolfhard in season one
there was a two-month build-up to that
scene for millie about just how
disgusting and horrible it was going to
be and she questioned the whole time why
the duffers wrote it in that definitely
reminded them that she was only 11 years
old not the character well that too she
survived though number five lego myego
i'm gonna be sick after being spun
around and around and around in one
scene in the void poor milly lost her
eggos we can't say we blame her that
looks intense
in a post she captioned it you spin me
right round baby right round ah threw up
after this this isn't the first time
millie's thrown up on set either at
least so the duffer brothers thought she
was pretty bold in season one to prank
the creators and we pretended that i was
really sick and we put water in my mouth
and then she started puking up the water
classic
number six a glossy finish that still
manages to look just
terrible daker was covered head to toe
in lip gloss to achieve that flayed look
not just lip gloss though also dirt and
mud not just lip gloss dirt and mud but
also an extra layer of lip gloss to seal
it all together
sounds like a party number seven milli's
nose bleeds are pretty wild so before
the scene starts she has to pour the
fake blood up her nose they immediately
start filming and basically hope for the
best as far as timing goes fun fact
that's the reason she tips her head down
when she's using her powers to get the
goo moving there are two kinds of fake
blood well probably a lot more but two
different categories of fake blood
there's the kind you wear and the kind
that goes inside your body for millie's
nosebleeds she was using corn syrup
number eight we're not done with the
internal goo yet though the edible blood
that is usually consumed via the mouth
and not the nose has to be made safe for
the actor and well one thing you don't
have to worry about when it comes to
noses is
taste but the mouth is a whole other
story the edible blood tastes pretty
freaking disgusting but as stranger
things progressed their concoctions got
a little tastier it's just an added
gesture from the makeup team to make the
fake blood taste better among the
options for flavor are emergency and
jello number nine while this might seem
like a delectable treat to most noah
schnapp was having none of it along the
lines of the bloods there's sometimes a
need for discoloration and head of
makeup amy forsythe wanted will byers to
look ill so they faded out the color on
his tongue you'd think green food
coloring and frosting wouldn't be such a
bad combination but turns out schnapp
hates frosting hey you can't please
everyone for all the torture forsythe
put will through with frosting he was
given permission to enact his revenge
and got to spray amy with a super soaker
number 10 caffeine is always the answer
david harbor is coated in mud sorry not
mud sticky espresso grounds that the
makeup team stole right from the
espresso maker in the trailer and the
recipe had to be exact no substitutions
coffee just isn't good enough it has to
be espresso and popper was covered in
mud a lot in season two while harbor was
a good sport about it amy said he was
happy for the hot towel at the end of
the day
number 11. sometimes it isn't the gross
prosthetics sometimes it's the actors
themselves being gross filming in a bus
isn't normally a sign of alarm unless
one of the boys is so gassy the bus has
to be evacuated more than once poor
millie was furious with her stinky
co-star it's never been revealed who cut
the cheddar which is very kind of them
to keep it under wraps we guess but this
wasn't an isolated event david harbour
admitted they would sometimes fart
during takes yep
kids little human beings with big
important jobs farting during cakes i
won't say which one
number 12. eating cold burgers and fries
is definitely not as satisfying as
eating cold pineapple pizza yes way back
in season one millie was eating cold
burgers and fries a lot of cold burgers
and fries like a lot a lot like too much
for an adult male to stomach let alone a
10 year old girl
we mean like at least three burgers in a
single sitting poor milly they always
encourage actors to eat healthy and then
they do this to them
number 13. that feel when they get you
when you're down poor jo kiri had to
film while sick this was more common
before the days of the dreaded pandemic
he was super stuffed up to begin with
but then to get the redness in his eyes
they blew menthol into them ouch he was
already a gooey snotty mess before the
staged beating came into it he also had
to have prosthetics applied to his face
he had a swollen jaw lump a cut split
lip and a mix of cotton and dried blood
here's hoping the appendages were sneeze
resistant number 14. eggos are actually
just the worst when you eat them
straight out of the box we recommend a
flamethrower whenever you see actors
eating food in a movie just know they
were in for a miserable few hours
because one ego on screen is like two
dozen in front of the camera we bet
millie will never look at eggos the same
way again number 15. was this one more
disgusting for the actors or for us
definitely us the leg you're looking at
isn't even millies in this scene it was
totally just prosthetics all decked out
with different layers of yuck luckily
the moving mind flare was added in
post-production and wasn't some creepy
animatronic below the surface honestly
we couldn't stomach if it were any more
real than it already is
while the disgusting blob of rat bodies
that merged to become a monster would
have made a great addition to this list
if you haven't already figured it out
only the animators were tortured with
that job what moment from stranger
things grossed you out the most let us
know in the comments and thanks for
braving all the disgusting stuff to hang
out with us here at the things